no the world isn't literally shrinking
but for humans it kind of is up until
five hundred years ago nobody had ever
even circumnavigated the globe but
nowadays anyone can do us at a couple
days just by paying a couple thousand
dollars therefore in the perspective of
today's humans the world is much smaller
than it used to be in the time that it
took for the first circumnavigation of
the world today's humans could fly to
Mars back twice think about this to
today's human the moon seems
significantly closer than America seemed
to Europeans in the 16th century when
the first voyage is departed it only
takes humans 3 days for the moon versus
over 2 months for the colonists go to
America
up until 1693 nobody had ever been able
to circumnavigate the globe as a tourist
as in paying for their own transit on
public transport Gemelli kerreri was the
first person to do this feat and it took
him five years David spring bed has the
current record of this accomplishment
with his journey from Los Angeles to
London to Bahrain to Singapore to
Bangkok to Manila to Tokyo to Honolulu
then back to Los Angeles in 44 hours in
6 minutes in 1800 you couldn't even get
from New York to DC in those 44 hours
between the years of 1857 and 1930 the
time it took to cross the United States
went from about three or four weeks to
one day not only has the time of travel
plummeted but the accessibility has to
46 percent of Americans will travel exer
the u.s. in their lifetime adjusted for
inflation the average cost of domestic
air travel in the US has dropped by more
than 50 percent in just the last 30
years 50 years ago only 20 percent of
Americans had ever flown on an airplane
but today only 20 percent have it
in some ways this may be saddening
there's less to explore there pretty
much no places left on earth that are
inaccessible to the average human being
one can travel to every continent every
ocean every country with relative ease
however this does mean that practically
anyone with thirst of adventure can
visit every continent ocean or country
in the coming years we will have even
more to explore as we look up to the
Stars and leave earth we can already buy
our tickets to go to outer space and
although it might not be feasible for
the everyday human to buy their ticket
now just look how fast the price of air
travel plummeted by the end of our
lifetimes going to the moon might just
be as easy as flying Europe